I'll tell you as a humongous fan of
Death Note I am speechless that they
actually granted a wish I've had for
years for the longest time I thought I
was the only massive Death Note fan that
also truly appreciated its roots an
eighties soft rock I can't believe they
finally understand me Death Note dist
directed by Adam Wingard and is on
Netflix now and yes I did get a new
tattoo I actually got this today I was
able to put on a short with sleeves this
time because this one doesn't hurt as
much right now because we only did ink
and shading there despite the fact that
that looks very red there's no red ink
here that's just blood vessels yeah it
doesn't exactly feel great but I got
Samus starfox and a link this time and
I'm very glad that I did because my
artist is amazing Bethany Hendrix I love
you you're incredible thank you very
much let's talk about this film that I
saw called Death Note I happen to be a
giant fan of the anime the last few
episodes did kind of run off the rails
when they did something to my favorite
character in the show but before that it
was pretty much perfect anime so I was
very excited while also being terrified
about seeing this adaptation because as
you guys know anime adaptations scare me
at the same time I'm happy when I see a
studio recognizing the importance of
anime and trying to adapt it for more
audiences because that's something I've
always tried to promote on my channel
that anime has had a major influence on
American cinema and cinema all around
the world really and so I'm glad
whenever someone tries and what I can
say about this movie is that Adam
Wingard definitely tried he's not just
throwing things at the screen there are
strange stylistic choices yes very odd
sound
tract choices that's for sure when it
comes to music if you couldn't tell I
was being completely sarcastic in the
opening but you can tell that he
actually is putting forth effort to try
to make competent film this is not a
throwaway disaster like The Last
Airbender or Dragonball Evolution but
all that being said I was pretty
disappointed in the long run because
certain things involving characters have
been changed so much from the anime and
manga and I understand that changes have
to be made I did not sit down ready to
hate this movie as soon as I press play
but in the original anime light Turner
is a genius he gets a book that falls
from the sky known as a Death Note and
the Shinigami God rheic tells him that
if he writes any name in this book while
picturing that person in his mind he can
kill that person in any way in which he
writes down in the book and he
eventually develops this persona called
Kira this godlike entity that he wants
to make people believe is watching over
everyone taking out terrible criminals
and terrorists and all kinds of
murderers and the people seem to really
like this thing that's developed because
of this Death Note a detective named L
who's brilliant but very introverted and
strange is also on the case now these
two people have a great cat-and-mouse
game and that's the anime certain puzzle
pieces of that are in this movie they
got certain things right L is very weird
he loves sugar he often hunches over in
his chair he doesn't like to wear shoes
this is a pretty good portrayal of L
light turner however not too much of
anything like he was in the anime in the
show he turns from a genius kid to a
genius kid who's also kind of evil and
they captured that evil turn in this
movie where he starts to enjoy what he
does but it's for all of the wrong
motivations here in this film he seems
to want to try to kill people in his
Death Note to impress this girl that he
likes which is the oddest character
choice and it's so conventional they've
taken characters that are very complex
and extremely compelling in the original
Japanese anime and manga and they've
made them your stereotypical teen
archetypes of these types of movies and
I don't get why for
the first 20 minutes of Death Note I'll
be honest I was actually kind of
interested to note falls from the sky he
meets Rioch played in this film by
willem dafoe
amazingly Ryoka is easily the best part
of this movie the Shinigami God and the
anime was this death God that basically
explained all of the rules to lights but
he also had a way of manipulating him
because he didn't really give a he
kind of just wanted to see was like the
Joker in the Dark Knight he just
appreciated chaos I relished every
minute on screen with Ryoga they really
got this character right he's barely in
the movie though I needed way more of
real it's like they didn't realize the
best thing that they had going for him
and they barely ever utilized this
really awesome looking monster god thing
that could have been so cool if they had
him in more for those first 20 minutes I
was thinking okay they've changed a few
things but this is competent then they
decide to do a montage sequence that
skips some of the most compelling things
about the show when he becomes the
persona of Kira and decides he's going
to kill terrorists and all these
organizations and take on criminals they
montage through this in minutes and then
all of a sudden the whole world is like
thinking Oh Kira's great Elle shows up
in the game of cat-and-mouse starts but
it montage through so much development
so the film feels so rushed because of
that there just wasn't enough motivation
for why light turns more towards evil
beyond he has this girl there and they
kind of team up and they like each other
so yay I didn't go into this movie
wanting to hate it I was actually really
pulling for him I was hoping it would be
good you can look at this movie and say
well you're just judging it because
you've seen the anime and you're
comparing that okay let's just take
Death Note out of it
take the anime out of it I've never
heard of Death Note before does it work
as a film sure you can watch it the
characters are fine the special effects
are fine it has a compelling idea but
the issue that I have with it as a movie
is that towards the middle portion it
loses so much dramatic weight because we
speed through a
very integral part of lights life and
I'm not even talking about the anime
anymore
you start the movie and he's a normal
high school guy and in five minutes he's
a sociopath
it just it was such an awkward jump
there's a lot of strange stylistic
choices as well and an effort to make it
more friendly to American audiences when
it really didn't have to be there's this
big action chase scene it just felt way
too American and that's one of my
biggest issues I think with Western
adaptations of Japanese material you
have to honor the culture that this is
coming from I understand that an
adaptation for America is for America I
also understand that a lot of the
creators of Death Note liked this movie
and I've said in the past that it's hard
for fans of things especially anime or
comic books to let go of their cherished
love for something because we often feel
like we take ownership of characters
that we love or shows that we love and
we have to understand that we don't own
these characters and if the creators are
happy good if the creators are happy
with this movie cool I'm glad I'm not I
think that they drop the ball
the casting choices also could have been
better and there's been enough talk
about that already so I'm not gonna add
any fuel to the fire Death Note is a
movie that should have been very dark
and very thematically rich because of
the implications of a young kid in
school who has the ability to kill
anyone he wants but this movie becomes
sort of a why a romance with slow motion
dance sequences and a tease soft rock
very strange choices and it disappointed
me I'm gonna give Death Note
a c-minus guys thank you so much as
always for watching look forward to my
review of good time and some more
Stephen King reviews I didn't have any
time to film anything else today I got a
tattoo I watched Death Note I filmed the
review oh and yes I actually am going to
color this too I forget if I just
mentioned that this is gonna be like
full color but this just the ink in the
shade alone was four hours today
so nothing after that I was like we're
good we're good guys thank you so much
as always for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
steppen eyes
[Music]